hey today we have voice check Zaremba
and we're going to talk about AI so
voiture could you give us a quick
background I'm a founder at open AI and
I'm working on robotics I think that
deep learning and AI is a great
application for robotics prior to that I
spent a year at Google brain and I spent
a year at Facebook a research and saying
am i graduated from I had finished my
PhD at NYU can you explain how you
pulled that off the team is pretty rare
so the great thing about both of these
organizations is that they are focused
on research so throughout my PhD I was
actually publishing papers over there I
highly recommend both organizations as
well as of course open AI yeah okay so
most people probably don't know what
open AI is so could you just give that
exponent Oh open AI focuses on building
AI for the good of humanity and we are a
group of researchers and engineers
collaborating together who essentially
try to figure out what are the missing
pieces of articles of general artificial
intelligence and how to build it in the
way that would be maximally beneficial
to humanity as a whole open area is
greatly supported by an Elan mask and
some Outman and in total we gather an
investment of 1 billion dollar a group
which is quite a lot into whatever I'm
in I know some but what are the open
area projects so there is several large
projects going on simultaneously we have
also we are doing also a basic research
so let me first enumerate a large
projects and these are robotics so in
terms of robotics we are working on
manipulation we think that manipulation
is the complex it's the one of the parts
of robotics which is the most unreal
and result sorry just to clarify what
does that mean exactly it means that so
in robotics they're essentially three
major three major families of tasks one
is locomotion which means how to move
from let's say how to walk how to move
from point A to point B second is
navigation it so you're moving in the
complicated environment such as for
instance as flat or a building and you
have to figure out actually to which
which rooms which ones have you visited
before which net and where to go and the
last one is manipulation so this means
and you want to grasp an object let's
say open an object place objects in
various locations and the third one is
the one which is currently the most
difficult so it turns out that when it
comes to arbitrary objects current
robots are unable to just grab an
arbitrary object for any object it's
possible to hand code a single solution
so say as long as same Factory D had
same object again I don't know we are
producing classes and there exist hand
coded solution to it there is a way to
buy code to write a program saying let's
play their hand in the middle of the
class and then let's close it but there
is no way so far to write a program such
that it would be able to grasp an
arbitrary object okay gotcha
and then just very quickly the other
open API projects gonna so another one
has to do with playing a complicated
computer game and third one has to do we
linked large number of computer games
and you might ask why it's interesting
and in some sense would like to see ya
and that so human is
has an incredible skill of being able to
learn extremely quickly and it has to do
with a prior experience so let's say
even if you haven't played ever a
volleyball if you try it out for the
first time in within 10 or 15 minutes
you would be able to grasp how to
actually how to play and it has to do
with all the prior experience that you
have from from different games if you
would put the child like if you would
put an infant on their volleyball court
and ask him or her to play and it would
fail miserably but I mean due to the
fact that it has experience coming from
large number of other games or let's say
other life situations its able to
actually transfer all the knowledge so
at opening I were able to pull together
a large number of computer games and
computer games can be it's quite easy to
quantify how good you're in the computer
game currently best AI system so so
first of all it's possible for many
computer games to write program that
solves it pretty well or plays it well
and there are also results from that
there are results in terms of
reinforcement learning or in terms of
so-called deep reinforcement learning
showing that it's possible to learn how
to play a computer game these are is
that the initial results are coming from
midnight and but simultaneously and
simultaneously it takes extremely long
time like in terms of real time
execution to learn to play computer
games so for instance Atari games when
for for instance in terms of real time
execution in text as having around three
to three years of of play
learning to play simple games I mean it
can be hugely paralyzed therefore etx
few days to Train it on current
computers but but it's way shorter for
human because in 10 minutes we can kinda
teach you how to play and win it ok is
that through giving you feedback so the
way how it works in case of computer
games and the feedback comes from
computer from this course so it looks at
the score in the game and tries to
optimize it and say that's kind of
reasonable but I would say simultaneous
is not that satisfying to me so the
reason why it's not that satisfying to
me so the assumption underlying
reinforcement learning is that then
there is some some environment and
environment you are an agent and you're
acting in environment by executing
actions and getting rewards from the
environment and the rewards might be
taught as let's say pleasure or so and
the main issue is that it's actually not
that easy to figure out what are their
rewards in the real world further on
other underlying assumption is in being
able to reset environment to kind of get
too repetitive the same situation and so
the system can try thousands or millions
of times to actually finish a game so
there are some small discrepancies
people also believe that it might be
possible somehow to hard-code into
system rewards but I would say that's
actually one of the big issues that it's
kind of unresolved like when I look how
my nephew plays computer game he
actually doesn't look in on score
because he cannot read and still - yeah
they can play pretty well so I mean you
can say maybe reward is somewhat
different maybe reward comes from I can
sing a nice hearing nice voice in the
game or so but I would say that's
something what is very unclear how to
how to build a system and what system
should optimize so son says if we have a
metric that we want to optimize it's
possible to build a system that could
optimize for it but it turns out that in
many cases it's not that easy and I
would say that's actually one of the
motivations why I wanted to work on
robotics because in case of Robotics
it's way closer to the system that we
care about so what I mean by that for
instance let's say you would like your
robot to prepare scrambled eggs for you
and so the question is so how to how
should I deal their reward and in
computer games actually the last thing
is they are getting reward extremely
frequently so let's say anytime you kill
an enemy or let's say won't die it's
quite great but in case of scrambling
eggs
it would mean or the way how people
write rewards for systems it would mean
distance from hand to app and then let's
say somehow you have to quantify what
then if the egg it's if you were able to
crack open an egg or let's say if that
if you fried its efficiency and how to
how to kind of quantify it turns out to
be extremely difficult and also there is
no way even to reset the system how to
reset register them anyways so ok these
are like a two dimensional issues and
the reason why I'm personally interested
in robotics is thinking that actually
these challenges will tell us how to
solve so let's start by defining a
couple things so what is artificial
intelligence what is machine learning
and then what is deep learning ok they
start pretty good and these are pretty
good questions ok so artificial
intelligence is actually extremely
brought the it's extremely broad domain
and the machine learning is sub part of
this domain and
ss artificial intelligence consists of
any writing any software that tries to
solve some problems through some
intelligence it may be hand coded
solution rules rule-based system
yeah so pretty much it's actually very
hard to say what is not artificial
intelligence you can say that so initial
version for instance of google search
was based on it it was avoiding any
machine learning and it was there was
like a well-defined algorithm called
PageRank and essentially PageRank counts
how many incoming links are from other
websites and that artificial
intelligence it's a search item that
that's intelligent things for you and
then over the time and Google search
started to use machine learning because
it was it helps to improve results at
similarity they wanted to avoid it for
some time I have more difficulty to
interpret the result and it's more
difficult to actually understand what
system does so what is machine learning
machine learning it's essentially a way
of building or let's say that
essentially you have data and you would
like to generate based on data program
with some behavior so like the most
common example which is still sub branch
of machine learning so-called supervised
learning so you have pairs of examples X
comma Y which means like a I would like
to map X to Y for instance either if
given email is spam or not spam or let's
say even image what is the category of
an image or for instance
to whom should i recommend given product
and based on these date it would like to
generate the program some sort of the
black box or some function that for new
examples would be able to give you
similar answers that's an example of
supervised learning but this is machine
learning means that you would like to
generate program from theta okay and
this usually uses statistical machine
learning method so somehow you can't
somebody but how many times even event
given events occurred or so okay gotcha
and then the third being deep learning
so deep learning that's also that's kind
of that's one paradigm in terms of
machine learning okay and idea behind it
ridiculously simple okay so I am people
realized that if you want to as I said
machine learning means that you get data
as an input and program as the output
and deep learning says that the
computation of the program then though
there what I'm actually doing with this
data should involve many steps not one
step but many ok and pretty much that's
it in terms of meaning of deep learning
so you might ask why it's so popular now
and how it's so different from what was
there before things turns out that if
you assume that you do one step of
computation let's say that you take your
data and you kind of have single if
statement or small number of each
statement then I guess for instance so
if you have a you know let's say your
data is
or is a recording from a stock market
and they are saying you're gonna sell or
buy depending on value speaker or
smaller than something or if if let's
say depending or who is the new
President or so we are making some
decisions so that sense turns out that
in case of models that are based on
single step people are able to prove
plenty of stuff mathematically in terms
of models that require multiple steps of
computation mathematical proofs are
extremely weak and for a long time
models that do single step of
computation they were outperforming
models that do many steps of computation
but recently it kind of changed and it
it was for many people it was obvious
for a long time that true intelligence
cannot be done in single step but it
would require many steps but so far many
systems actually they worked in the way
that they had kind of very very shallow
they were very shallow but
simultaneously extremely gigantic so
what I mean by that you could generate
let's say for for the task of interest
and let's say their recommendation you
could generate large number of features
let's say thousands of them these are
features saying for instance from let's
say you want to do movie recommendation
you can say is movie longer or shorter
than two hours is it longer or shorter
than one hour that's there are two
features you can say is it drama is it
trailer is it something and you can
generate million of these and then or
let's say 100,000 that's actually quite
reasonable value and then your shallow
classifier can determine based on the
combination of these features either to
recommend it to you or not
okay in case of deep learning he would
say let's kind of combine it for
multiple steps
and that entire difference and in case
of deep learning the most successful
embodiment of deep learning is in terms
of neural networks okay
so let's define that - so neural
networks it's also extremely simple
concept and recognizing that people came
up with a long time ago
and means and then it means as follows
if you have an input its might be say
vector or it might have some additional
structure like a let's say image so it's
kind of a matrix two dimensional and
heal neural network it's um it's a
sequence of layers layers are
represented by matrices and what you do
is you multiply your input by a matrix
and apply some nonlinear operation and
multiply it again by a matrix and apply
nonlinear operation you might ask why
would I even need to apply this
nonlinear operation turns out that if
you would multiply by two matrices it
can be reduced to multiplication by
single matrix like a composition of two
linear operators can be written as
single linear operator you could
multiply these matrices together and the
result of the and and you could condense
it into single matrix and non-linearity
is something like that there and
classical don't in ret but early so say
there are extremely large number of
variants in terms of what I said but
what I just described is so-called
feed-forward neural network so it
essentially takes input multiplied by
matrix non-linearity multiplied by
matrix examples of non generic
if there is something that one which is
classical something called sigmoid so
sigmoid is a function that has a shape
of s character and letter it's kind of
close to zero for negative values it
grows to house at zero and then goes up
to one when the values are larger the
kind of modulates the input and that's
the most classical version of activation
function it turns out that the one which
is even simpler empirically works way
better which is called reloj rectified
in our unit and this one is ridiculously
simple reloj
it's just maximum of 0 co max so when
you have negative values at 0 positive
value just copy the value and that's it
so you might ask so first of all what
are the successes of deep learning why
we actually believe that it works why
what change and why it's so much
different than it was before and they're
like a sub-q yeah this is a good
question that's exactly where I was
going to go but I was going to ask
beforehand yeah why why neural networks
are I think now I'm supposed to in the
past the main difference is all the
sudden we can train them to solve
various problems and let's say one
family have problems these are problems
needs to provide learning so better than
any other method they can map these
examples to labels and then on the
holdout they account test data they
outperform anything else and in many
cases they get superhuman results and is
that just a function of like
computational power that we have access
to when it comes to models and neural
networks is an example of model there is
always a question so how to figure out
in terms of a model so there is some
training procedure and the most common
procedure for neural networks is
so-called stochastic gradient descent
it's a also ridiculously simple
procedure and turns out that empirically
it works very well so people came out
with vast number of learning algorithms
a stochastic gradient descent is an
example of one learning algorithm or
others let saying there is something
called heavy on learning that motivate
like that's motivated by the way how
Nene grows in human brain learn but this
one so far
empirically is working the best okay
so then let's go to your question you
ask yourself which is why now like
what's happening to make people care
about it right now and so and so since
twenty years ago and there were several
small differences in terms of how people
train your networks and him there is a
large increase in compute computational
power so I can speak about the major
advances so number one advanced
I would say that's even the dopant the
one advance that's actually an old one
but it seems to be an extremely critical
something called convulsion illiberal
Network okay now does that mean I'm
there so it's actually a very simple
concept so let's say your input is an
image and let's say your image is of a
size 200 by 200 and has also let's say
three colors so that would let the
number of values in total is actually
hundred twenty thousand so if you would
actually squash it into a vector this
vector would be of this size okay and
then I can think that if you would like
let's say to apply numeral network
essentially multiplied by a matrix and
let's say if you'd like to have output
of the multiplication of similar size
say 120,000 then all the sudden the
matrix to multiply it would be of a
gigantic size and learning their
learning consists of estimating
parameters the neural network
appearances that empirically that
wouldn't essentially work that if you
would use algorithm of back propagation
you would get quite full results and
people realized that in case of images
you might want to multiply by a little
bit special matrix that also allows to
do way faster computation so you can
think that neural network as it applies
on computation to the input so near a
network apply some computation to the to
the input you might want to constraint
if computation in some sense so you
might think as he will have several
layers maybe initially you would like to
do very local computation and it should
be pretty much similar in every location
so you would like to apply the same
computation in the sense there are in
the corners maybe later on you need some
diversification but you want to
pre-process image the same way so the
idea is that when you take an image or
any actually to I've mention of
structures so other example is you can
take voice and it turns out that you can
by applying fullier transform you turn
boys into image and all day it's like a
to remember a waveform it's a yeah so
you take a waveform yeah and you apply
for your transport okay and essentially
on the x-axis you have time as the
speech
goes on and on y-axis you have different
frequencies and that that's an image and
speech recognition systems they also
they they treat sound as it would be an
image
I mean realize that that's really cool
okay so that's why I'm saying that the
technique that I could did it did also
like a kind of as a side track yeah the
cool thing about neural networks is it
used to be the case that people
specialized in processing text images
sound and these days this is the same
group of people that's really cool they
do we are using the same method so
coming back to what is control ocean
along Africa
yeah as I mentioned you'd like to apply
the same computation all over the place
in image and essentially convolutional
neural network says when we take an
image let's just let's just connect a
new neuron with local local values on
the image and let's copy the same weight
over and over again so this way you will
multiply kind of multiply values in the
center in the corners by the same same
values in there in the matrix okay as an
input and add so input the conversion is
an image and out to this kind of also an
image can think that there is also some
specific vocabulary so in that this is
kind of three-dimensional images like
you have height and you have also depth
so let's say in case of image that three
dimensions and then you apply
convolution you can kind of change
number of depth dimensions usually
people go to let's say like 100
dimensions and so okay gallery and then
you kind of have several of these layers
and then
there are so-called fully connected
layers which are just conventional
matrices so I would say that's one of
advances that actually happened 20 years
ago over another one which is it might
sound kind of funny but for a long time
people didn't believe that it's possible
to train deep neural networks every
Wednesday where they were thinking quite
a lot about what what are the proper
learning algorithms and it turns out
that and so let's say when you train a
neural network you start off by
initializing weights to some random
values and appends out that it's very
important to be careful to what
magnitudes you initialize weight and if
you set it to right values and I can
even give you some let's say intuition
what it means turns out that then
simplest algorithm which is called
stochastic gradient descent actually
works pretty well okay so some sense as
as I said say layers of neural network
tape kind of multiply they multiply
input by matrices and a property that
you would like to retain its you don't
want the magnitude of our values to blow
up and also you don't want it to shrink
down and if you kind of multiple if you
choose random initialization it's easy
to just some initialization that will
kind of female turn that the magnitude
will keep on increasing and then if you
have ten layers and let's say in each of
them you multiply by 2 to 2 to 2 and
then the output all the Sun is of
completely different magnitude and
learning is not happening anymore and if
you just choose them and it's a method
of choosing variants like a magnitude of
initial way and if you set it such that
say output is of the same magnitude as
input and everything works so
basically just adjusting those
magnitudes was what proved that you
could do this with a neural network yes
Wow okay that's kind of ridiculous that
the let's say people haven't realized it
for a long time but that's what it is
and when did when and where did that
happen and it happened actually at the
University of Toronto so them at the
Geoffrey skintone lab so then crazy
thing is people had several schemes in
terms of how to train deep neural
networks and one was called generative
pre-training and so let's say there was
some scheme what to do in order to get
to such a state of neural network that
all of a sudden you can use him this
trivial algorithm called stochastic
gradient descent so there was like an
entire involved procedure and at some
point and Geoffrey asked his didn't you
know compare it to like added a simpler
solution which would be adjusting
magnitudes and like a showing how big
difference there is crazy man I don't
like that okay so that a question that's
a little bit broader is just like then
what has happened in the past say five
years to excite people so much about AI
so I would say them most Fanning were
so-called
an image that result so first of all I
should tell you where was computer
vision five years ago then I will tell
you what what is image net and then I
will tell you about the results so
computer vision is a field where
essentially you try to make sense of
images like a computer tries to
interpret what is on images and it's
extremely simple to say out here on an
image there is a cow a horse or or so
but for computer images just the
collection of numbers so all the large
matrix of numbers and it's very
difficult to say out
like how to it's very difficult to
interpret what's their content and it
was the case that people came out with
very skins how to do it and you know you
could imagine a lady let's quantify how
much of a brown color there is such that
you can say the horse again I guess
simple stuff whether people of course
came out with more clever solutions but
assistants were quite better I mean you
could fit the picture of a sky test
system and it was telling you that there
is a car that's like a good yeah so then
then faithfully right Bailey is a
professor at Stanford she together with
her students she she collected a large
data set of images and data set is
called image net it consists of 1
million images and one thousand classes
so that was by the time actually the
largest data set of images in a class
just to clarify being like car might be
a class yes so there is that the data
set would say it's not artifact it has
for instance he doesn't contain people
that was one of constraints over there
it contains large number of breeds of
dogs so that's like well that's a queer
key thing about it but the same time I
mean that's the SSI data said that made
deep learning happen types of dogs and
now then as the act of it's so large so
so kept America there was like a plenty
of teams actually participating in
emotional competition and and say even
as I'm saying there is 1000 classes over
there so if you have a guess random
guess then probability that your guess
is correct is essentially
0.1% the metric there was slightly
different deal actually if you make five
guesses and if one of them is correct
and New York you are good
okay because there might be some other
objects and so on and and and I remember
when I for the first time when I have
seen that someone might you know and
that system was that someone created a
system that had 50 percent error I was
impressed okay else like oh man it's
like I guess what are the classes and it
can it can say okay with fifty percent
error what is there I was quite
impressed but then during competition
like a pretty much like all the teams
got around 25 percent there all right
there like a deep there was a difference
by one person there like a for instance
a team from University of Amsterdam
Japanese team like a plenty of people
around the world and a team from
University of Toronto led by Geoffrey
Hinton and that's like a dad on team was
Alex Reshevsky and Ilyas cover they
actually cut to something like fifteen
percent so let's say all other teams
they were like a twenty five percent the
difference was one percent yeah and
these two guys they got to fifteen
percent okay yeah and crazy thing is
that week in so so so so within
following three years on these data said
the error dropped dramatically I
remember I can't next year the error cut
to let's say 11 percent eight percent
all kind of you remember by that time I
was wondering what the limit how good
can you be and I was thinking five
percent that's like at that's the best
and even even there they're like a
human's trying to see how far they can
get if they spend arbitrary amount of
time on let's say looking on other
images and kind of comparing to be able
to figure out what is there I mean it's
it's
not that simple for human for instance
if you have plenty of breeds of dogs and
like a who knows but let's say if you if
you can if you can use some external
images to kind of compare and so on that
that that helps but in a sense within
several years people cut down I believe
to three percent error and that's the
such a superhuman performance and as I'm
saying it used to be the case that
systems in computer division you take a
picture of a sky they were down here is
a car and all the sudden they are
getting to superhuman performance and it
turns out that these results actually
are not just limited to computer vision
that people are able to get amazing
other systems let's say speech
recognition because that's like the
underlying question right because like
it's not I mean to someone not in the
field like me it's not necessarily
intuitive that computer vision computer
image recognition would you know seed
artificial intelligence so I mean like
what came after that so in that says the
the crazy thing is that the same
architectures yeah work for various
tasks and all the sudden that the that
field which seem to be unrelated
I started benefit from each other so so
I mention it turns out that problems in
speech recognition can piece of in very
similar way you can sense I take speech
apply Fourier transform and then speech
starts to look like an image and he'll
apply similar object recognition network
to kind of recognize what are the cells
over there
and like a phonemes and so fun inside
like a kinds of sensor better and then
you can turn it into text and so that's
why we're so it went to speech after
images and
yeah then them next big thing about SSI
translation translation was extremely
surprising to people that's result by
aliases covered so translation is an
example of another field that actually
leaked their Python and one of the crazy
things about translation is input is of
a variable length and output is a
variable length and it was unclear even
how to kind of consume and with neural
network how to produce variable length
input variable length output and and
ileum came out with an idea there is
something called recurrent neural
network so I mean let's say recurrent
neural network and convulsion on the
world apart a shared an idea which is
you might want to use the same
parameters if you are doing similar
stuff
and in case convolutional network means
let's share the same parameters in space
let's say let's apply the same
transformation to the middle of image as
in the corners and so on and in case of
recurrent neural networks this s as well
being
reading text from left to right I can
consume first word can create some
hidden state representation and then
then then next time step when I'm
consuming next word I can take it
together with this hidden representation
and generate next hidden representation
and we are applying the same function
over again and this function consumes
hidden representation and next word
hidden representation and the word
hidden representation of the word so
it's relatively simple the cool thing is
if you are doing it this way regardless
of the length of your input you have the
same size of a network and the way how
his model worked and described in
in paper called sequence sequence
essentially calcium work by word centers
that you want to translate and then when
you're about to generate translation you
essentially omitting work by word and at
the handy art when you have meat dot
that end so cool and it was quite
surprising to people by the time they
got to decent performance they were not
able to beat a phrase based systems and
now it's it's like outperform very like
a long time ago already and yeah that
one other issue that people have
so if Newell at work systems like in
case of frustration the problem with
deploying it on the large scale is that
it's quite computationally expensive and
it requires a giant and in deep learning
literature there are various ideas how
to make things way way cheaper
computationally after you train it so
it's possible to throw away a large
number of ways or as I shall turn floats
32-bit float into smaller sized numerix
and so on and so forth and pretty much
that the reason why things are not
largely deployed in production systems
out there but neural network based
solutions are actually outperforming
anything what is out there there are a
couple more things I would like to just
define for a general listener so there
are a couple words being thrown around a
lot so narrow AI general AI and then
super intelligence can you just break
those part sir so pretty much all AI
that we have out there is narrow AI no
one built so far general AI no one built
a super intelligence so narrow AI means
artificial intelligence so it's like a
piece of software that solves a single
predefined problem general AI means the
piece of software that can solve huge
vast number of problems on all the
problems so you can say that human is
general it's general intelligent because
you can give an arbitrary problem and
human can solve it okay but for instance
bottle opener canceled on the bottle
opening so pretty much when we look at
any tools out there at any software and
our software it's good in solving single
problem for instance our chess-playing
programs cannot drive a card and for any
problem we have to create a separate
piece of software and general artificial
intelligence is an exam is a software
that could solve arbitrary problems so
how we know that it's even doable
because we in there is an example of a
creature that has such a problem and
then super intelligence is I assumed the
next area especially super intelligence
means that it's more intelligent than
human am cool so given all that given
that like we're basically at a state of
narrow AI across the board at this point
where where do you think is like what's
the current status of this stuff where
do you see it going in the next five or
so years so as I mentioned they're
essentially machine learning they're
third parties also paradigm so then one
of them is supervised learning there is
something called as supervised learning
there is also something called
reinforcement learning and
so far then the supervised learning
paradigm is the only one that works
solely murkly remarkably well that it's
ready to be applied in business
applications all other are not free
either and so you ask me where we are so
we can solve this problem other problems
they require further work it's very
difficult to plan with idea how long it
will take to make them work the thing
which is very different with
contemporary artificial intelligence is
that we are using precisely the same
techniques across the board
simultaneously majority of business
problems can be framed as supervised
learning and therefore they can be soft
with current techniques as long as we
have sufficient number of input examples
and what you want to predict and as I
mentioned the first can be extremely
rich I can output my dear sentence and
current systems work pretty well with it
and nonetheless it requires an expert to
train it and so then given the given
like pretty substantial hype we see when
you think of it all this the field is
simultaneously under hyped and overhyped
so from the perspective of business
applications as long as you have pairs
of examples that purse from ICANN that
indicate mapping okay what the input was
the output so we can pretty get pretty
pretty up and get to superhuman
performance but in all other fields we
are still not there and it's unclear how
long it will take
so give some example let's say for
recommendation systems you have often
companies like Amazon they have examples
of million millions of users and they
know what they bought when they were
happy or not and that's an example of a
task that is pretty good for neural
network to learn what to recommend to
new users simultaneously and Google
knows what is the good search query for
you because on the search result page we
are clicking on the links that you are
interesting and therefore they should be
displayed first and in other fields it's
actually quite often more difficult ok
in case of let's say apple picking robot
it's difficult to provide supervised
data telling how to move an arm toward
Apple therefore that's way more
complicated same time the problem of
detecting where Apple is it's where
better define and can be outsourced to
human to add note 8 plenty of images and
to give localization of the Apple and
quite often the rest of that problem can
be prescriptive by bike engineer but the
problem of how to place fingers on an
apple or how to grip it it's it's not
well scientifically solved and so a
couple questions that at this point if
if people were to be interested in
learning more about AI and it may be you
know working with open AI are doing
something how would you recommend they
get involved in educate themselves so
say a good place to start is Coursera
course there is pretty good there is
also a lot of tensorflow tutorials
tensorflow is an example of framework to
train URL networks okay I also answer a
car Patti's class at Stanford it's
extremely accessible you can find it on
I believe on YouTube yeah and then like
in terms of them actual exercises so in
case of tensorflow
tutorial and many of the problems so I
believe in case of Andres class there
there there there there might be
homework and in case of tensorflow
exercises it's quite often easy to came
up with some random talk after let's say
reading okay
I mean you can take for instance let's
say like a simple task over there is
let's classify let's classify digits and
let's classify pictures of digits that
assign them classes you can try my being
download some some images from some
other source like a flickered let's try
to classify it the word taxes okay so so
given that you guys are working on with
robots at this point one of the other
like things that's thrown in like kind
of part and parcel with AI is automation
specifically of like a lot of these
low-level blue-collar jobs what do you
think about the future maybe the next
ten years of those jobs so I believe
that will have to to offer to people a
basic income I super strongly believe
that actually that's the only way so I
don't think that it will be possible for
40 years old taxi driver to reinvent
himself every 10 years I I think it
might be extremely hard
other crazy thing is people define
themselves through job and that might be
another big social problems
simultaneously they might not even like
their jobs like if you ask someone would
you like your kid to to the sell in a
supermarket to be a seller in the
supermarket they would answer no and
maybe it's possible to leaving the work
that there is abundance of resources and
people can just enjoy their life I think
we're gonna have to figure out a way I
mean maybe maybe people will always find
purpose but I think like making it
easier to find that purpose will become
much more important in the future if
automation actually happens to the
degree people talk about and what about
what about just like influences on you
that like maybe have inspired you to
work with robotics and an AI are there
any like books or films or any media
that you really enjoyed it's pretty good
the book called Komodos actually
describes the history of humans and then
speaks that and has various predictions
about the future where we are heading
that's one pretty good hmm
I mean there is no advice there is like
a plenty of movies about AI and how it
can go wrong what's the best one I think
hair is pretty good okay yeah ex machina
is also pretty good cool alright do you
have any other last thing you want to
address looks nuts no thank you okay
cool thanks man
you